[Music]
okay everybody I am so excited today
because Georgina Campbell is back on the
show she is now starring in Barbarian
we're going to be talking spoilers about
the film in this interview so please
make sure you watch the film first
Georgina how you doing today
I'm good it's so nice to see you again
hello yes I I'm honored you're back that
means I guess I did okay the first time
uh so
first off though how crazy is it for you
being in the center of a poster for a
big Studio film like this like I
literally see this Barbarian poster with
you everywhere I go so how surreal has
that been for you it's been really weird
when I first saw like the poster design
my agent sent it to me and I was like oh
my God how can I get one how can I get
one
um so I spent ages getting my agents to
pester Disney to get me to get me one of
the uh posters so I've got about 10
posters now I don't know what I'm gonna
do with them all
um but no it was so exciting it's just
so cool yeah I wouldn't have ever
imagined it it's great no it's great and
it's great to see someone who is just
long deserving of big roles like this
and big exposure now with the character
of Tess Marshall it's very interesting
because this film is really blocked in a
lot of different parts and I just want
to start from the beginning of the film
too because she's dropped into this like
very modern situation of having a rental
being double booked now the first half
of the film is very more tamed to me
than the second half so are you
approaching it as a horror film in your
head in that first half of the film are
you kind of looking at it differently
no I think well I think the Way It Was
Written was that it was written to be
like a kind of rom-com
um so not that that was necessarily what
Zach said he didn't say come at it as a
rom-com but the Way It Was Written was
very much kind of like romantic comedy
but the fact that it's in the horror
genre like you don't have to work too
hard to make it suddenly appear kind of
sinister and especially having Keith be
played by Bill Skarsgard who everybody
knows as being quite a Sinister actor I
like playing lots of roles
um so it was just yeah we just got to
kind of it was really lovely because it
was a nice way to start out the film
before everything goes absolutely insane
and have these nice scenes with Bill and
just kind of build their relationship
and kind of create the like almost will
they won't they it's like a Meek you
they end up in this place together and
um I think it's fun and then obviously
you kind of get the horror like comes
out of nowhere really it kind of smacks
me over the head really fast yeah and
that's so interesting you mentioned the
meat cute because it definitely has
those vibes which I loved and it's
interesting though with Tess you know
meeting Keith in the first half not
knowing him it's a complete stranger to
her did you avoid even meeting with Bill
Pryor to film like how did you guys kind
of plan that out and how did you build
such good chemistry as the film goes on
I you know what we me and Bill had met
before we both were on a TV series on
Amazon called soul mates we were on
different episodes but our episodes were
filmed um consecutively so we met very
briefly at like a wrap party and hung
out and then suddenly it was like oh my
God this is so weird like here we are
working together
um and it was very short period of time
but Bill came in bill came in and we
filmed the beginning of the film and
then Justin came in so it was very quick
and I think we just got lucky I just a
chemistry is such a weird thing it it
really has no Rhyme or Reason
and we just really worked and we got on
and
um and it was written really well as
well so and I just think we had fun with
it and yeah it just felt very easy
um so yeah I'm glad that that chemistry
worked between us I mean he's such a
great actor so he could probably have
chemistry with like a plank of wood
it's so impressive to see like I love
seeing that so quickly how two strangers
you guys can build that relationship so
convincingly as this phone was on it's
really brilliant and I also wonder too
now just going to the middle part of
this film you're going from being in a
two-hander to now a solo show in the
middle does that become more daunting
for you and even like lonely at times on
set
honestly we filmed the film so fast
but I don't think there were really kind
of outstretched um periods of time where
I felt like I was alone
um it was I was speaking to someone
about it the other day and I didn't
actually really notice that much being
alone I think especially because Zach
was so Hands-On he was always very
present and very much in the actor's
corner and it was like a small
production and everybody was kind of
behind each other so I never felt
particularly lonely or concerned
um so yeah because I suppose you know
once you start getting down into the
basement there is lots of scenes where
it's just me but also I mean I think for
a lot of it my boyfriend actually came
and was on set a lot as well so like in
between takes I'd just be sat with him
having a chat so I definitely didn't
feel lonely oh that's good so also too
it's impressive because in that solo
performance you're having going through
the basement and we're with you as an
audience it's also really good on your
part the physical performance of it and
I'm wondering
how conscious review of that like is it
tough to pull off having the physical
part and emotional part in those scenes
and not feeling like silly or like am I
doing this exactly how you want without
having a scene partner is that strange
yeah I think some of the the nice the
physical stuff that I suppose I noticed
the most was stuff with the lighting
where we had to light and having to hold
the camera the the phone at the right
position and move the light and be
thinking about that as well as thinking
about you know acting and the emotion
and everything
um but once we'd kind of got that down
it became quite easy
um and I think it was just I think that
first when we first go down the steps
and there's lots of me yelling Keith
like Non-Stop and I remember when we
first started filming that I kind of
gave a few kind of lackluster keys and
Zach was like no no this needs to be
like the end of Blair Witch where she is
screaming where you think this person
like could be dead like you need to like
lose your [ __ ] and then kind of as soon
as he said that I was like all right
well that's it we've got to go for it so
from then on it was like falls to the
wall completely going for it
um and so was very helpful in kind of
pushing that along definitely yeah and
and when the the movie like you said
just goes insane territory I'm wondering
too you're in these dark hallways and
obviously it's brighter on set but is it
like claustrophobic because it seemed
kind of tiny the set like what kind of
set were you in there what did that feel
like
yeah they built those Halls that the um
the kind of corridor
um and they were very small everything
got shut in there were parts of it that
could be taken out
um but really it was it's interesting
because when the camera and everyone is
behind you then obviously you can kind
of get lost in it and it's very
claustrophobic and very dark and scary
but for the scenes where the camera's on
your face
um it's you know there's a camera guy
there's the boom operator there's you
know the guy doing the focus and
everyone's kind of squeezing down this
like hallway like it was kind of
ridiculous but
um it was very well designed it looked
amazing it did and it looked like you
were kind of having fun on set too which
is awesome and you know it's crazy
because like again you just going back
to you saying a perfect thing with the
meet cute what I think blows people's
mind is we get in that mindset and then
the most terrifying character appears
the mother
um was she as terrifying in person and
what are you actually seeing on set with
her
it was all practical which was amazing
that was something that Zach told me
right at the beginning that everything
was going to be practical
um because he's kind of really into
those like all kind of 80s style horror
films
um so I mean it was amazing I think did
I meet Matthew before I can't remember
when I met Matt I think I met Matthew
before so I had this vision of you know
Matthew's like a very good looking sweet
nice person and then seeing him suddenly
being in the kind of mother you know
that all the Prosthetics and everything
it was just completely different like he
they're just miles apart and his
physicality and everything he did in the
world was so good and yeah he was
terrifying you know he's very tall as
well and very kind of domineering and
um yeah those scenes were really really
really terrifying but then you know you
call cut and it's Matthew being like are
you all right how's it going oh okay
because you're also blowing my mind
right now because I didn't even realize
it was a man playing the mother
that's insane so also too this this
movie does another 180 and introduces us
to AJ which becomes now your scene
partner with Justin long so did you
shoot your scenes with Justin in order
after Bill and how was it working with
Justin Long
did so we shot everything with Justin
first and then
um I mean with uh Keith with Bill first
and then we uh moved on and Justin came
and then some of it was kind of you know
out of order the way it is when you film
um but it was it was really great I mean
he came in just as we'd kind of started
getting to those really big pieces and
everything starts going a bit crazy and
the acting is really getting perched up
um and then it was interesting obviously
because he kind of has a second act that
I'm not in so I kind of had a bit of
time he did his stuff I was there for
some of the stuff he was doing which was
really exciting to watch and you know I
think one of the first days he came in
he was doing stuff in the Airbnb and I
was there to watch it and it was just
such a different tone and like really
exciting to watch and he's just
absolutely hilarious
um and then we come together and it was
really fun working with him he's you
know obviously a really amazing actor
and the character itself I think the
first scene that we did is where we
realized that Tess is still there in the
pit and we see each other and it was
just a brilliant scene and he was just
so funny in that scene with his kind of
like bewilderment of what the hell is
going on and her having been there for
you know weeks kind of trying to explain
to him shut up and listen to me
um yeah it was great yeah it was such a
good scene and it's great when you guys
are together on screen and it's
interesting just the character
relationship because to me it feels like
there's a lot of faith Tess has in AJ
even to the point where she wants to
save him and then he completely betrays
her and pushes her off a freaking water
tower yeah so how do you think this will
change Tess's views on men people in
general just kind of going to like her
character Journey for me if you can yeah
I mean it's so interesting I hope it
doesn't change her too much I think you
know Tess doesn't know AJ so she doesn't
know the kind of person that he is
and I think it's you know it's Gallant
to be trying to help people maybe she
should you know look after herself a bit
more in the future
um but I do think that moment where he
throws her off the tower is kind of you
know a big eye-opening moment and then
obviously you get tests suddenly you
know finally putting her foot down and
saying I'm not gonna go back like I'm
done with this I don't want to come back
with you
um so I think by the end of the film you
get the idea that she's ready to stand
up for herself and ready to look after
herself and not necessarily put men uh
in front of her own needs which I think
you kind of get like a little inkling of
that with um when she talks about her
ex-relationships and that she's kind of
used to being in relationships with men
where she's not necessarily being heard
or she's not being treated well and she
kind of perseveres even though it might
not be the best thing for her so I think
she gets a like a girl power moment at
the end oh yeah yeah I like that
connection too that point earlier in the
film that's great and
also I think everyone talks about this
leaving the theater this moment which I
thought was powerful and made me think a
lot was the headspace of tests that you
know she's originally scared of the
mother rightfully so but then the mother
like saves her here and yeah is there
any thought in this moment that
of not shooting the gun at her was there
a thought there in Tessa's mind to not
do it
I think it's you can see in that moment
that it's painful and for her she's
she's understanding mother a little bit
more because I think at that point the
audience knows more about mother really
than necessarily she does we do get you
know she does get a little bit um when
they get uh you know they go off with
the homeless guy
whose name in it I can't quite remember
um and he kind of says you know she's a
copy of a copy there's you know she's
not the worst thing in there but
actually AJ has a lot more information
of what's been going down in that
basement than Tess does
um but I think yeah the fact that she
saves her and then there's a very sweet
tender moment that Matthew creates
um but at the same time you know she is
a monster she's a she's been made to be
a monster but
um going back into that house with her
is not going to be great no one wants to
drink any more of that milk bottle so I
think she makes the right choice at the
end but it's a sad choice I I totally
agree that's a that's a great answer too
and now it's interesting we see Tess
walk off so could you see a sequel to
Barbarian and have more story here with
the character of Tess
I don't think so I think Zach is not
looking to do another word which I think
is smart I think sometimes you know I
think this is such a good
original
bizarre film that I think it would be
hard to follow it and there would be a
lot of pressure to follow it and I think
sometimes you know sometimes stories
just need to stay one you don't always
need to have a prequel or a sequel
sometimes it's you know it's almost
special nowadays to get just one but
people really enjoy and you leave it at
that and leave them wanting more yeah I
totally agree with that that's a great
smart thought there too
I I also it's got to be exciting for you
too that this is like really to me one
of the big kickoffs to this historic
Horror Season we're having and Barbarian
Just Landing with audience and critics
so how does that feel to have such a
positive response to this film you
worked really hard on and do you peek at
all reviews reactions or do you kind of
not even look at that
I mean I really shouldn't but I've been
obsessed with this one I
think he loves the film and it's it's
been something that's been on my mind
you know from the moment we filmed it so
kind of waiting for it to come out to
you know speaking to Zach along the way
and finding out how things are going on
to finding out you know that Disney came
on board and we're going to distribute
it to finding out that it was going to
be in cinemas across the US and now it's
you know it's about to go to Cinemas in
the UK which is huge for me you know
coming from there
um it's been this slow development of
like oh I mean it's going well behind
the scenes how's it going to do when it
comes out and I just don't think any of
us really quite expected it to have the
kind of response it's having and that
it's like you know the critics like it
and people like it and you know they get
it and they love how weird and strange
it is and you know having spoken to Zach
and knowing that that was a big reason
that people didn't want to make the film
that that's the reason that people like
the film it's just it's just really
lovely and also I was speaking to
someone the other day and it almost like
I mean very narcissistically but almost
affirms your taste level and that you
can look at something and go I think
this is actually going to be really good
and do really well that doesn't always
work but I think knowing you know
reading this script and having I had an
immediate feeling of like excitement and
like oh my God I have to be in this this
is going to be amazing and then this be
the reaction is just kind of like a
lovely ending to the whole journey of
getting into this film yeah yeah that's
exciting and I love you saying like this
is a Brave movie I think that's what
people really respect about it and it
lands and it was a risk and it was
rewarded which is awesome now the horror
fans are gonna are passionate fan base
they're gonna fall in love with Georgina
Campbell now so can we get another maybe
a little tease for your horror project
coming up lovely dark and deep if you
can say anything about it yeah I mean I
don't know it's so hard I haven't heard
that much about it recently you know
what it's like you do it and then you
know everyone goes off and the post
happens and everything
um but it's a really beautiful film
written by uh Theresa Sutherland who did
uh the wind which I thought was such a
gorgeous film an amazing kind of like
horror drama
um and this is very similar it's very
much a story about one person which is
my character and
um following her I don't even know how
much I'm meant to say because I don't
know what is out there on the on the
internet but she's basically kind of a
park ranger whose uh sister goes missing
and then she kind of goes on this
mission to find out exactly what
happened to her sister and it ends up
being that there's something kind of
sinister going on in the in the forest
yeah so just saying Sinister you got
everyone in so Sinister
um Everybody in the meantime obviously
just keep going tell people about at
watch Barbarian theaters now where
Georgina Campbell stars as Tess Marshall
she has a brilliant job per usual this
is expected with Georgina Georgina thank
you for coming on again and I hope to
talk to you in the future yeah
definitely thank you so much for having
me it's really lovely